نحييكم مشاهدينا الى ساعه اخباريه مفصله
من العربيه سنخصص معظمها كالعاده لتخطيط
التطورات في السودان
ونختم بملفات اخرى نبدا بالعناوين
الدعم السريع يعلن تمديد الهدنه في
السودان الاثنتين وسبعين ساعتين استجابه
الدوليه والاقليميه
[تصفيق]
البنك المركزي السوداني يؤكد ان اموال
المذيعين في الجهاز المصرفي امنه ويعتبر
ان عمليه السرقه لا تؤثر على الودائع
واليوم العاشر تمضي عمليات الاجلاء لرعايه
دول العربيه والاجنبيه والاسيويه
والعربيه في بورسودان حيث مركز الاجلاء
الرئيسي عالقونا يطالبون بالخروج
وفي اخبارنا الاخرى كذلك في هذه الساعه
قائد فاجنر يشكو نقطه ذخيره ويحذر من ان
الهجوم الاوكرانيه المضاد قد يشكل ماساه
لروسيا
[موسيقى]
ونحييكم مشاهدينا الى التفاصيل قبل انتهاء
الهدنه الخامسه في السودان اعلنت قوه
الدعم السريعا هدنه سادسه هذه الهدنه
كسابقاتها لمده 72 ساعه تبدا من منتصف
الليله لفتح الممرات الانسانيه ولتسهيل
الوصول الى المناطق الامنه الى الان لم
يصدر او لم يصدر الجيش السوداني ورد فعلا
على تمديد الهدنه ولكن ايضا في الاعلانات
السابقه كان الجيش يؤكد موافقته في وقت
لاحق ورغم الهدن المعلنه الا ان الالتزام
الكامل بها يبقى منقوصا فعلى مدار الايام
الثلاثه الماضيه كانت الاشتباكات متفرقه
في الصالحه والحلفايه وجبراء وصحافه حتى
خلال هذه الهدنه يتم التبادل الاتهامات
بين الجانبين الدعم السريع يقول ان الجيش
لا يحترم الهدنه والجيش من جهته كذلك يقول
انه يبسط سيطرته على معظم الخرطومه
ايضا هنالك طائرات
تتحدى هذا هذه الهدنه وتضرب في الاطراف
وتضرب
وتحول
مواقع ما يسمع من رصاص ومضادات الدعم
السريعه الارضيه تتصدى لهجوم طيران لكن
على ارض الواقع في ولايه الخرطوم في كل لا
توجد قوات مشاهده للجيش او قوات تتحرك من
مكان الى مكان للجيش هذه مساله حسمت من
الايام لا يوجد تحرك للجيش داخل ولايه
الخرطوم
السيطره كامله على كل الولايات 17
والسيطره
يعني بنسبه 80%
في ولايتي الخرطوم واما ولايه غرب
الفردفان غربي دارفور فهذه هي طبعا بها
متغير ومتغير الاخير الذي تمثل في اندلاع
الصراع القبلي والذي يعني الان يجري
احتواءه بواسطه السلطات المحليه هناك عن
طريق لجنه امن الولايه وهذا المسلحه يعني
تسيطر تماما على جميع مقراتها بما فيها
القياده العامه بما فيها بيت الضيافه وحتى
منطقه القصر الجمهوري حديثهم يعني
وتركيزهم على السيطره على العاصمه ليست
ليس ليس صحيحا
امام حركه الملاحه لمده اسبوعين اي حتى
الثالث عشر من مايو المقبل واستثنى قراره
تمديد اغلاق الاجواء طائرات الاجلاء
والمساعدات الانسانيه على ان يتم ذلك باذن
المسبق من سلطه الطيران المدني السوداني
من جانبه قال الممثل الخاص للامين العام
للسودان رئيس بعثه الامم المتحده
المتكامله للمساعده الانتقاليه في السودان
فولكررت قال انه لا توجد الى الان مفاوضات
مباشره بين قوه الدعم السريع والجيش
السوداني
ليس مباشره
هناك تحضيرات
لمحادثه
او
لتحضير محادثه
بين الجانبين
بعض الدول الاقليميه والدوليه
تشتغل مباشره
مع الجهتين
هذه الجهود انا شخصيا كمان باتصال مباشر
مع جانبين
فان شاء الله
سنرتب باقرب وقت ممكن
لقاء مباشر بين ممثلين
القوات المسلحه والام السريع كي نصل الى
اكثر من هدنه الى وقف اطلاق نار منظم اكثر
باليه مراقبه
ومشاهدينا من ام درمان صحفي شهدي نادر سيد
جودي اهلا بك معنا شهدي نبدا بالوضع من
عندك اخر التفاصيل كيف هي في ام درمان
اليوم مدينه ام درمان مع هدوء
ملحوظ كانت اليوم تحلق بعض الطائرات
المقاتله وكذلك اصوات المضادات بشكل متقطع
ودويب اسلحه في جنوب مدينه ام درمان وكذلك
في
شرقها الان الاوضاع هذا الى حد
لا نستمع حتى الى صوت المتقطع
لاصوات ذوي الاسلحه او المضادات اليوم
منطقه السوق الشعبي في ام درمان تعرضت الى
بعض المحال هو يعد ثالث ان لم يكن ثاني
اكبر سوق في المدينه تعرض لهجوم من
مجموعات متفلته اقدمت على انها بعض
المحاله التجاريه وبعض افرع
المصارف هناك ولكن عموما يمكنك كانت مسلحه
هذه الجماعات او هذه المجموعات
هذه هذه الجماعات تعرف شعبيه في السودان ب
9 طويله هي مجموعات تمارس النهب بالسلاح
الابيض كانت نعم هي منتشره والان تستقل
هذه الظروف الامنيه المعقده عاودت لانتشار
في عده مناطق في العاصمه الخرطوم في
الخرطي في مدينه الخرطوم وكذلك في مدينه
الخرطوم بحري والان اضحت تنامى هنا في
مدينه ام درمان
ليس هناك حضور للشرطه شرطي صحيح
للبدؤه في النزول في الخرطوم اعلنت الشرطه
انها ستنزل بالتدريج
بالتنسيق مع القوات الامنيه لكن حتى الان
لم تنزل بشكل كلي هنا في مدينه
انظروا معي وعليه هناك حاله خوف خوف هناك
حاله توتر من تكرار مثل هكذا عمليات نهب
وسرقه باستخدام العنف شهدي
نعم هي من المؤقت هذه هذه المجموعات قالبه
ما تثير الزعر والهلع وسط المواطنين هي
حتى الان تكاد تكون في مناطق محدوده ولكن
الخوف من ان تتمدد هذه
المجموعات في عده مناطق في مدينه ام درمان
نعم وضحت هذه الفكره ولكن في مقابل هذا
الوضع الصعب المتوتر اساسا كيف يبدو توفر
الضروريات الحياتيه من اكل وشرب ومواد
تطبيب ويعني كل هذه المستلزمات هل هي
متوفره بشكل كافي
علمت قبل قليل من مصادر ان هناك مستشفى
متخصص للاطفال مستشفى عام في مدينه ام
درمان مستشفى الامين حامد مركز قسيله لكل
الخاص به الاطفال المصابين قد لم يستطع ان
يعمل بسبب قربه من المقر الاذاعه
والتلفزيون نتائج العمليات القسط المتواصل
ندره الاطباء وصعوبه وصولهم الى تلك
المناطق هذا هذا هذا المركز قسية لايكولا
هو توقف بشكل شبهي هناك صعوبات ما تزال
على المستوى الصحي اغلاق المستشفيات
واخلاقها في وسط في وسط العاصمه القى بعين
اضافي على المستشفيات الطرفيه التي تعاني
من عدم قدره الاطباء على الوصول من
الاعداد الكبيره للمرضى الذين كانوا
ايستشفون في مستشفيات داخل العاصمه
الخرطوم وفي نطاق مناطق
العمليات كذلك الادويه بدات
شهدي اسمح لي ان اعود بك خطوه الى الوراء
كنا نتحدث منذ قليل وحدثنا كذلك عن
هجوم قامت به مجموعات مسلحه باسلحه بيضاء
لسوق شعبي وهذه صور في الواقع صور للعربيه
عن
صور متداوله
هناك اصوات يمكن ان نستمع للفيديو ثم نعود
[تصفيق]
بنك الخرطوم
[موسيقى]
بنك الخرطوم فريق السوق الشعبي
[تصفيق]
بنك الخرطوم
شهدي اعود لكم من جديد في الفيديو هناك
حديث عن هجوم قامت به هذه المجموعات على
بنك الخرطوم
نحن نتحدث عن استهداف لسوق في اندرمان طيب
ساعود لهذه الصور فقط ان كان لك بعض
التعليقات او ان كنت يمكن ان تضيف لنا بعض
التفاصيل وان كنت بعيد عن هذا الموقع ولكن
هل من تفاصيل اضافيه لانه الصوت في
الفيديو يقول بنك الخرطوم
نعم هو مقر فرع بنك الخرطوم في المنطقه
هذه الصوره هو
الخرطوم في اندرمان طيب وضحت الصوره
والبنك مجاور للسوق صحيح وتم استهداف
المنطقه
هو داخل يقع داخل السوق بجوار بنوك اخرى
ايضا متداوله ان البنك فرع
بن اخر يسمى بنك السلام ايضا انه جرت
محاولات
لنهبه كذلك عدد من المحاله التي تبيع مواد
البناء والمولدات الكهربائيه بحسب افادات
اشخاص هناك انها قد تعرضت ايضا الى عمليات
نهب واسعه هذه المجموعات
ريم كانت قد حاولت ان تدخل الى سوق ام
درمان اول من من امس من منطقته الشرقيه
تصدت لها سكان الاحياء الشعبيه منعوا
توقلها داخل السوق لممارسه اعمال النهب
هذه
وهي مستمره يبدو بان اعمال الناهب في
الواقع مستمره من خلال على الاقل ما يردنا
من فيديوهات وكنت اكدت منذ قليل شهدي بان
الشرطه لا زالت لم
لا زالت ليست حاضره يعني في انظر مان طيب
بالعوده للوضع الانساني كنا نتحدث منذ
قليل حدثتني عن المستشفيات ولكن هل المواد
الغذائيه متوفره كان هناك حديث عن مخزون
شارف على الانتهاء هل المغازات التجاريه
مفتوحه مثلا هناك قدره شرائيه
يعني جيده خاصه في هذا الوقت صعب
كما تعلمين ما يوجد في المنازل لقد نفت او
قد شارف على على النفاذ نزل المواطنين
هناك ما نطلق عليه البقالات الصغيره هذه
قاليتها اصبحت خارج الخدمه لجهه النفاذ ما
لديها ولكن هناك محال كبرى ومولات ما تزال
تعمل اليوم بعضها عاود العمل بطاقته
القصوى لديه مخزون ولكن هذا المخزون ايضا
متوقع ان ينفذ خلال الايام المقبله اليوم
كذلك بدا بعض المخابز ترفع من
اسعار الخبز لجهه ارتفاع كلفته الله
الانتاجيه كما يقول بعض اصحاب المخابز
اشكاليه للوقود وعدم توفره في القنوات
الرسميه وصعوبات التي تواجه المواطنين في
الحصول عليه عبر عبر المحطات الى الاسواق
الموازيه خلق عبر اضافيا في عمليه تصنيع
الخبز في عمليه ترحيل
اسئله على اساسيه وكل ما يحتاجه المواطنون
ارتفاع كبير في اسعار المواصلات العامه
التي بدات ايضا في ان تعاود العمل منه الى
الاسواق في بعض الخطوط ولكنها باسعار
مبالغ فيها يصيبها المواطنون بانها مبالغ
فيها بانها لانها اسعار خياليه في مقابل
ذلك يقول
الاسعار تابعناها حتى ليس كما يتعلق
بالموارد الغذائيه فقط حتى فيما يتعلق
مثلا في كل شيء صحيح
فيما يتعلق مثلا بيتذكر الحافلات
وتذاكر الحافلات مع هذه الحركه من النزوح
يبدو بانه هناك مشكله على مستوى التوافر
الحافلات وكذلك غلائها هل اندرمان لا زالت
اولا تشهد حركه نزوح مهمه وكيف هو توفر
الحافلات وكيف هي اسعار التذاكر هل هي
حركه منظمه مثلا من يؤمنها من يشرف عليها
نعم ام درمان تكاد تكون على عكس يعني
سكان المدن الاخرى ما يزال مواطنها
متمسكين متمسكين البقاء في منازلهم من
اضطروا للخروج اما في في بعض المناطق
اشتباكات او او مناوشات او لانعدام بعض
الخدمات الكهرباء او المياه ام درمان تشهد
استقرار نسبي كما قلت لك
التيار الكهربائي به بعض التذبذب ولكنه
متوسط الى حد ما بشكل افضل خدمه متوفره
يعني طيب
الاكيد باننا سنبقى في متابعه كل ذلك
ساكتفي معك بهذا القدر جهد نادر وشكرك
جزيل الشكر كنت معنا من ام درمان
حاليا نحن في المنطقه بتاعه المرسى مدرسه
المواطنين السكان في المنطقه
المجاوره تيجي تشيل المويه من هنا مباشره
من النيل شيلوا مويه بتاع الشرب شيلوها من
النيل من المرسى وانت ماشي
شديد جدعاني
تتحرك بيهم المناطق الصدريه كلها تجيبيه
وهنا والمنطقه خطيره شديد يعني
[موسيقى]
وفي تطورات سودانيه اخرى قال المتحدث باسم
اللجنه التمهيديه لنقابه اطباء السودان
الدكتور سيد محمد عبد الله للعربيه قال ان
الوضع كارثي في المستشفيات وفي المراكز
الصحيه مشيرا الى ان 70% من المستشفيات
خارجه عن الخدمه اما المستشفيات المتبقيه
فتعمل بشكل جزئي للطوارئ وللاصابات بحسب
قوله الوضع كارثي في هذه
المستشفيات والمراكز الصحيه
حتى كما تعلمون سبعين بالميه من هذه
المستشفيات خرج تماما عن الخدمه 61 مستشفى
من جمله 86 مستشفى في منطقه الاشتباكات
توقفت تماما عن العمل وهذه الخمسه وعشرين
مستشفى التي بقيت تعمل بشكل بعضها او
معظمها يعمل بشكل جزئي ويقدم زعافات اوليه
للطوارئ وللاصابات
اعلنت لجنه الدوليه للصليب الاحمر عن
ارسالها لاول شحنه مساعده انسانيه من
العاصمه الاردنيه عمان الى بورتسودان
وقالت اللجنه في بياننا شحنه المرسله
مؤلفه من ثمانيه اطنان من المعدات
الجراحيه لدعم مستشفيات السودان ومتطوعي
جمعيه الهلال الاحمر السوداني بالاضافه
الى مواد تخدير وادوات التضميد ولوازم
خياطه الجروح وغيرها من المعدات الجراحيه
التي يمكن ان تستخدمها لعلاج الاف الاشخاص
الذين اصيبوا بجروحه جراء الاشتباكات في
السودان
بعد الرابع عشر من ابريل لم يتمكن احد من
الحصول على الدعم الطبي في البلاد التي هي
في امس الحاجه اليها نامل ان تنتقل هذه
المساعدات سريعا من بورتسودان الى
المستشفيات وهذا يتطلب احترام كلا
الجانبين وقف اطلاق النار حتى نتمكن مع
زملائنا من الهلال الاحمر السوداني من
توصيل هذه المواد في اسرع وقت ممكن الى
المستشفيات
امتدا القتال الدائر في العاصمه السودانيه
الى اقليم دارفور المضطرب غربيه البلاد
حيث شهد اشتباكات متقطعه بين الجيش
السوداني وقوه الدعم السريع عدا عن الفراغ
الامني الكبير الامر الذي يثير المخاوف من
اندلاع حرب اهليه
ايقظ الصراع العسكري والدائر في العاصمه
السودانيه الخرطوم ومحيطها صراعا اخر عمره
عقدان في الغرب البعيد من البلاد منطقه
دارفور
دارفور الواقعه في اقصى الغرب السوداني
تحظى بولاياتها الخمس باهميه استراتيجيه
كبيره لطرفي الصراع المتحاربين في السودان
فالاقليم يتشارك حدوديا مع اربع دول من
الغرب تشاد وليبيا ومن الجنوب افريقيا
الوسطى وجنوب السودان تسكن المنطقه قبائل
عده عربيه وافريقيه وسط وفره في الثروه
الزراعيه والحيوانيه والمعادن منذ اندلاع
القتال بين الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم
السريع منتصف ابريل تفاوت حجم العنف في
انحاء دارفور حيث تعرضت نيالا جنوب دارفور
والفاشر في الشمال لقتال عنيف في الايام
الاولى من الصراع لينحسر القتال فيهما
تدريجيا في الايام الاخيره ولينتقل بشده
وعنف الى مدينه الجنينه متسببا بمقتل ما
لا يقل عن 100 مدني وفق الامم المتحده
ومنظمات الاغاثه ونجد الاهتمام الدولي
يتركز اليوم على دارفور التي شهدت نزاعات
قبليه قديمه ومتكرره حيث يظهر فراغ امني
كبير يخشى مراقبون من ان يؤدي الى حرب
اهليه
خاصه مع تزايد التسليح بين المدنيين
وافراد القبائل المتناحره عدا عن اعمال
النهب والتدمير واضرام الحرائق في المنازل
والمباني الحكوميه هذا فضلا عن مخاوف من
ان تلجا قوات الدعم السريع للاحتماء في
حاضنتها هناك اذا تازمت الامور في باقي
الولايات لتشتعل الامور اكثر في الاقليم
كل هذه تطورات دفعت الالاف من السكان
المحليين الى الفرار الى تشاد المجاوره
والى جمهوريه افريقيا الوسطى بكل متاعهم
فيما يبدو وكانه رحيل بلا عوده
ملوك الشيخ العربيه
اثار انتشار قوات الاحتياطيه المركزي جنوب
الخرطوم معركه كلاميه بين الشرطه وقوات
الدعم السريع التي اتهمت الشرطه بالوقوف
طرفا في الصرع في المقابل اكدت الشرطه ان
الاحتياطيه المركزي قوه تابعه لها تعمل
على تامين الاسواق وممتلكات المواطنين
وضبط اي حاله فله امريكا كما تقول
قوات الاحتياطي المركزي السودانيه
هي قوه شرطيه تم انشاؤها عام 1990 وهي من
الادارات المهمه بقوات الشرطه وتقع
قيادتها بالكلاكله جنوب الخرطوم وتنتشر في
العاصمه والولايات تم تدريب عناصرها
للقيام بعمليات المسلحه وشاركت قبل اعوام
في عمليات قتاليه مع الجيش في ولايه
دارفور وجنوب كردفان والنيل الازرق وشرق
السودان سلاحها اقرب لسلاح الجيش وبها فرق
عمليات خاصه تتدرب على يد القوات الخاصه
بالقوات المسلحه بدات الانتشار يوم السبت
بجنوب الخرطوم على ان يتوالى نزولها
لمناطق اخرى من العاصمه هذه القوات خاضعه
لعقوبات امريكيه منذ مارس من عام 2022
بتهمه استخدام القوه المفرطه ضد محتجين في
الخرطوم
[موسيقى]
هذا الموضوع بالنقاش مع ضيفنا من الخرطوم
لواء ابو بكر ابراهيم احمد خبير عسكري
ولواء سابق في القوات الجويه اهلا معك
اهلا بك معنا لواء ابو بكر اسمح لي ان
ابدا معك باخر التطورات وهو بيان دعم سريع
اعلنه تمديد الهدنه الاثنتين 72 ساعه
انطلاقا من منتصف هذا الليل هل هذه الهدنه
وما سيترتب عليها خاصه يمكن ان تؤسس وتبني
لفتره دائما من وقف النار تعتقد
والله
لم يكن المشاهدين اهلا موضوع الهدنه نسمع
على وسائل
الاتصالات الخارجيه لكن نحن على الارض
الاصوات الرصافه تنقطع والحركه البائبه
بالنسبه للقوات الدعم السريع والجيش
مستمره
لا وجود لوقت
الوتيره حضرتك ربما قدر ان تعطينا صوره
ادق بما انك لك خبره في هذا المجال يعني
هل هي بنفس وتيره الايام الاولى ام خفت
وتيرتها
وبقت الاولويه لتخفيف الاقتتال وبعض
الاشتباكات المتفارقه
القوات الشرطه كانت موجوده قبل الحرب
وكانت تسيطر عليهم حتى الذين خارج السجون
اما الان
فالشوارع مليئه بالتي لم يدخل فيها الجيش
فيها الدعم السريع والدعم السريع
نفسه جزء منه يشارك في هذا الناس لذلك هذه
المشكله الاساسيه بالنسبه للمواطنين
الموجودين في الخرطوم
ولذلك
المواطن
صوته بما هو صوت الاعلى
واوصل اوصل صوته للسلطات الجيش
وكل هدفه الان ان يحسم الجيش هذه
المشاه
وتنزل قوات
الخاصه
[موسيقى]
لك
في انتظار ان يتم ذلك وحضرتك تتكلم ربما
عن مستويات متقدمه ولكن في هذه المرحله
الحاليه والبعض يسميها معركه كسر عظم في
الخرطوم خاصه
كيف يمكن
ان
تجد الاطراف حلا لانهاء معركه كسر العظام
هذه بمعنى انه ما المتاح هل الارض تبقى
الخيار الوحيد او حضرتك بحسب خبرتك ترى
بان الارض يوازيها شيء غير معلن في هذه
الاثناء هناك وسطات هناك محاوله للاتفاق
غير معلن في هذه الاثناء
انا مبتكر انه الدعم السريع
المسلحه القوات المسلحه كما ذكرت لك الان
هم في ضغط شديد من المواطنين ويطلبون منهم
المعركه في اسرع وقت ممكن
انا افتكر الارض هي الذي سوف
تفصل في نهايه المطاط الدعم السريع يحاول
بقدر الامكان التشبث في الارض ويحاول له
حوالي ثلاثه ايام يحاول
طلب امداد الى الخارج رغم ان
الطوابير من العربات تبع الرباعي تضرب
بالطيران لكن هو يحاول ويحاول في ثلاثه
ايام السابقه دمرت له اكثر من 4 عربه
العاجل لوبا بكر لتعلق عليه حضرتك الا ليه
الثلاثيه بالسودان تدعو البرهان وحماتي
للموافقه على تمديد وقف اطلاق النار 72
ساعه وكان بيان دعم سريع اكد موافقته
تمديد هذه الهدنه الاثنتين و70 ساعه ولكن
لم يصدر حتى الان موقف عن الجيش ما تفسير
ذلك
انا انا ذكرت التي ان الدعم السريع
يخرج بيانات انه يتغير بوصف اطلاق النار
وكذلك القوات المسلحه لكن في ارض الواقع
ليست هنالك وقت اطلاق النار حرب والشوارع
انت تنزل من الامارات
الدفع الرباعي تجد الدعم السريع والمواطن
يتخوف من وجود الدعوه سريع ويطلب من
القوات المسلحه ان تتدخل
القوات المسلحه
اصدرت بيانا انها بدات
اه تمشيط الارض وتنشيط الارض يعني ان
القوات المسلحه تدخل الى منطقه معينه
وتنظفها تماما من الجيوب الدعم السريع ثم
تترك خلفها قوات الاحتياط المركزي لتؤمن
المنطقه
التلفونات موجوده والاتصالات موجوده بين
المناطق المنطقه التي لم يدخل فيها جيش
فيها النهر والمناطق التي حررها الجيش
ونزلت فيها الاحتياطي المركزي ينعمون
صحيح وفي المقابل كذلك من يدعم الدعم
السريع يعني يطرح نفس هذه المخاوف على كل
اللوابا بكر الاكيد بان سنبقى في متابعه
كل هذا ساكتفي معك حتى الان بهذا القدر
شكرك جزيلا الشكر من الخرطوم اللواء ابو
بكر ابراهيم احمد خبير عسكري ولواء سابق
في القوات الجويه اود شكرا جزيل الش
المشاركه وكل ما تفضلت به ومشاهدينا نشير
الى هذه العواجل كنا نتابعها اسفل الشاشه
عن الاليه الثلاثيه بالسودان التي كما
ذكرت منذ قليل هي تدعو البرهان وحميدتي
للموافقه على تمديد وقفه اطلاق النار 72
ساعه وكذلك تدعو لاحترام وقف النار لان
الشعب بحاجه ماسه لهذه الهدنه كما تقول
الاليه الثلاثيه وتؤكد على ان وقف اطلاق
النار سيمهد الطريق لمحادثات بين الجيش
والدعم السريع اذا الاليه الثلاثيه تؤكد
على اهميه وقف اطلاق النار في هذه الاثناء
اولا خدمه
للهدنه الانسانيه وكذلك فتحا لامكانيه ان
تكون هناك محادثات بين الجيش والدعم
السريع
اول بدايه
في جسم مثال شرطه قعدنا محل الجسم طوال
الليله حرب جاي
دقيت لي التلفون
وامشي يعني هنا طوالي اتحركنا من هنا
ومشينا
اكد بنك السودان المركزيه على سلامه اموال
المذيعين في الجهاز المصرفي موضحا انما تم
تداوله من عمليه نهب او سرقه لبعض فروع
البنوك لا تؤثر على الودائع واعلن البنك
المركزي في بيان له ان معظم فروع البنوك
في السودان باشرت على تقديم خدماتها
المصرفيه لاسيما خدمات السحب والاداء
النقدي
هذا واظهرت مقاطع فيديو محاولات سرقه بنك
الخرطوم في مدينه او احد بنوك الخرطوم في
مدينه ام درمان نتابع
[موسيقى]
والله
حذر المبعوث الامريكي الخاصه باقي للقرن
الافريقي جفري فيلتمان في لقاء مع صحيفه
الجاردن من اطاله امد الصراع في السودان
لانه سيفتح الباب امام جهات خارجيه تدعم
جنرالا على حساب اخر بحسب قوله
الصراع في السودان الى منحا اخر وربما
ينتهي بتدخل خارجي لنصره احد جنرال النزاع
ما ينذر بحرب اهليه طويله الامد تقول
صحيفه الجارديان البريطانيه
الصحيفه نقلت عن الدبلوماسي الامريكي
ومبعوثها الخاص السابق الى القرن الافريقي
جافري قوله انه كلما طال امد الصراع سيسمح
لجهات خارجيه خبيثه بدعم جنرال على حساب
اخر
رجل امريكا السابق للقرن الافريقي اكد على
ان الساحه متاحه امام القوات الخارجيه في
اشاره الى مجموعه فاغنر الروسيه ولذلك
يتوجب وقف الاقتتال في اسرع وقت ممكن
لتقويد التحرك الخارجي تحذيرات لم تاتي من
فراغ على ما يبدو بعد ان كشف القائد
السابق لفاينر مرات جابيدولا
موجوده في السودان منذ نهايه العام
مؤكدا ان هناك 200 عنصر من الوحده
الهجوميه الاولى داخل الاراضي السودانيه
حيث كانت مكلفه بتدريب قوات الدعم السريع
والشرطه المحليه
التحذيرات جاءت ايضا من الداخل على لسان
قائد جيش عبد الفتاح البرهان الذي كشف عن
وجود مرتزقه داخل السودان قدمت من دول
تشاد
وافريقيا الوسطى والنيجر
رئيس الوزراء السوداني السابق عبد الله
حمدوك حذر هو الاخر من امكانيه اندلاع حرب
اهليه في السودان ستشكل كابوسا قاطما على
البلاد والعالم
محاسن حداره العربيه
المتحدث باسم العمليه العسكريه السياسيه
في السودان خالد عمر يوسف على حسابه في
تويتر حذر من انتشار المواجهات العرقيه في
البلاد في ظل احتدام الاغتال بين الجيش
وقوه الدعم السريع مشددا على ان استمرار
الحرب سيضعف الدوره المدني تلقائيا ويتحول
لدور هامشي مشيرا الى ان الموقف المدني
الديمقراطي يجب ان يكون بالضغط لوقف الحرب
وتكوين جبهه مدنيه ديمقراطيه واسعه مطالبا
بجيش واحد يتم الوصول اليه بالاتفاق على
خطط شامله للاصلاح الامني والعسكري تتضمن
تنفيذ الترتيبات الامنيه المنصوص عليها في
اتفاق جوبا للسلام ودمج الدعم السريع في
القوات المسلحه
من الخرطوم معنا مصباح احمد رئيس دائره
الاعلام في حزب الامم القومي والقيادي في
الحريه والتغيير اهلا بك معنا سيد مصباح
سيد مصباح مبدئيا ما تبعناه عن هده جديده
اكدتها او اكدها دعما سريع من خلال بيانه
اكدت على اهميتها الاليه الثلاثيه ولكن
ننتظر حتى الان موقف الجيش منها في كل
الحالات هذه الهدنه ما مدى اهميتها
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم تحيه لك
مشاهديكم في قناه العربيه
فعلا هذه الهدنه اهميتها تكمن في انها
تاتي امتداد
للهدن في وقت تسعى فيه كل الاطراف المحليه
والدوليه
لتثبيت هذه الهدنه وتطويرها عرض الحوار
المباشر بين جانبين الذي ينتظر ان يعقد في
خلال 72 ساعه المقبله من اجل الاتفاق على
وقف اطلاق النار وتحديد اليات مراقبته
ولذلك هي مهمه للغايه لانها تخفض التوتر
فضلا عن انها ايضا تقدم الاغراض الانسانيه
وكذلك تفتح المجال للمواطنين السودانيين
العالقين في العاصمه الخرطوم الخرطوم الان
في وسط المعارك بان يخرجوا الى الاسواق
ويا المحال من اجل قضاء حاجياتهم ولكن حتى
الان
وعطفا على كلام حضرتك
الاليه ثلاثيه اكدت ذلك واكدت كذلك بان
امكانيه تمديد هذه الهدنه سيفتح المجال
امام محادثات كذلك بين الجيش السوداني
ودعم السريع الى اي مدى حضرتك ترى بان حلا
كهذا يمكن ان يكون قريب المنال
نعم من الاشارات الايجابيه هي موافقه
الطرفين على الدخول في حوار وتسميه
ممثليهما في هذه المحادثات القوات المسلحه
والدعم السريع وينتظر ان تعقد هذه
المحادثات ما بين جده وجبه كمقترح وارجح
ان تكون في في جده باعتبار ان الاسره
الدوليه وكل الموجودين في بورسودان
وقريبين ايضا من جده يمكن ان يرعوا هذه
المباحثات وان يدفعوا بها الى الامام كذلك
ايضا هنالك جهود محليه كبيره جدا من القوى
السياسيه المدنيه تدفع باتجاه ضروره وقف
هذه الحرب والضغط على الاطراف حتى يعني
تكون هذه المباحثات المديه بهدف اول حاجه
وقف اطلاق النار بصوره دائمه وكذلك تحديد
اليات مراقبه اطلاق النار او وقف اطلاق
النار لانه الهجره السابقه السابقه لاحظنا
ان هنالك عدم التزام
سابقه اي وحتى في الساعات السابقه يعني
تخللت هذه الهدنه الشبكات ولكن حضرتك منذ
قليل تتحدث عن يعني امور بدقه تقول بانه
ان كانت هناك مفاوضات فهي ستتم اما في
جوبا او في جده هل افهم من حضرتك بان حزب
الامه القومي على علم ببعض التفاصيل
الاضافيه اللي ممكن ان تضعها لنا هل هناك
خيط بين الطرفين هل هناك وساطه الان جاريه
دون الاعلان عن تفاصيلها
نعم حزب الام القومي هو اول حزب يعني
اقترح هذه المفاوضات وخاطب المملكه
العربيه السعوديه رسميه بان ترعى مبادره
لجماعه طرفين منذ بدايه الحرب السيد رئيس
الحزب ارسل خطابا
لجلاله الملك
سلمان بن عبد العزيز من اجل رعايه هذه
المفاوضات ما بين الجانبين والدفع بها من
اجل التوافق من اجل وقف اطلاق النار
والطالب بالنسبه لنا يعني يحمد للمملكه
العربيه السعوديه وايضا الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه والزملائنا في القوه المدنيه
انهم ايضا مشوا في نفس هذه الخطوه وبدات
هذه الخطوات تمشي الى الامام في اطار
المبادره الامريكيه السعوديه نعتقد ان
المملكه
والمؤهله لهذه الوساطه ويمكن ان تفضي هذه
الوساطه الى نتيجه ايجابيه ايضا الاليه
الاليه او المبادره الانجاز التي طرحت
مؤخرا لا نهلها نرحب بها ولذلك الاطراف
ايضا رات اذا كان الحوار في جده او في
جبهه سيكون ايضا في نفسي اتجاه دعم
الطرفين لوقف اطلاق النار والوصول لنتائج
ايجابيه ولذلك الان تعمل نعم ما يتعلق
بالمبادره الامريكيه ممتاز تتحدث عن تنسيق
وتقول سيد مصباح بان حزب الامه القومي
يتواصل مع الطرفين طيب في اخر هذه الساعات
قد تختلف الكثير من الامور يعني مش مثل ما
بدانا اول ايام مثل ما وصلنا له اليوم من
تطورات على كل الصعود الان ما الذي يقوله
الطرفان لكم في خصوص الشروط يعني باي شروط
يمكن وقف اطلاق النار تماما
حكم المدني
وخروج المؤسسه العسكريه بالكامل عن معادله
الحكم والسياسي نحو نسعى مبدئيا الان الهم
الاساسي بالنسبه لنا هو ان توقف هذه الحرب
اولا ثم تحدد اليات مراقبه واضحه ومتفق
عليها من الجانبين وترعى من الاسره
الدوليه ومن ايضا المنظمات المحليه حتى
يكون وقت اطلاق النار ثابتا يهيئ المجال
الى استكمال المرحله المقبله من العمليه
السياسيه
كما تفضلت بالاشاره شكرا جزيلا لك من
الخرطوم مصباح احمد رئيس دائره الاعلام في
حزب الامه القومي والقياده في الحريه
والتغيير شكرا لك
[موسيقى]
قال السفير السعودي لدى السودان علي بن
حسن جعفر قال ان خطط الاجلاء من السودان
لا تزال قائمه وفق القوائم التي تقدم من
قبل بعض الدول او السفارات ووفق الطاقه
الاستيعابيه للسفن وطائره كذلك القياده
احتياجات الانسانيه للانسان في
السودان
والخروجهم من مدينه الخطوط بسبب الاعمال
القتاليه الراهنه حتى صدرت التوجيهات
باجلاء كل من يريد ان يتم اغلاق خلال فتره
السفن والطائرات خطتي الى ما زالت قائمه
لكنها
قوائم التي تقدم من قبل دونهم او سفارات
ونوم
نحقق فيها حسب الطاقه الاستيعابيه
للسفن والطائرات التي ترسل يوميا
واكد سفير السعودي لدى السودان علي بن حسن
جعفر ان السعوديه ليس لها اي تمييز
فالجنسيه او العرق هو ان عمليه الاجلاء
تكون وفق الوثائق القانونيه ووفق التنسيق
بين الاشخاص ودولهم
اننا ان يعني
حل مسائل الانسانيه
للناس ايا كانوا ليس لنا في هذا
الخطه الاجلاء ليس لنا تمييز في عرق او
جنس او جنسيه
من يريد الجلاء ولكن وفق
[موسيقى]
الوثائق القانونيه وفق التنسيق ما بين
الشخص المجذي او المجموعه التي يردد لها
والدوله
التابعينها
نعود الى الاوضاع الانسانيه في داخل
السوداني وفي بورتودان بتحديد رصد مرسل
العربيه نزار البقلاوه احوال العالقين
الذين ينتظرون الخروج من البلاد نحو اليوم
العاشر تمضي عمليات الاجلاء لرعايه الدول
العربيه والاجنبيه والاسيويه من شرق
السودان الى عدد من الدول في المنطقه اكثر
من نحو عشره الاف من رعايه الدول الاجنبيه
تم اجلائهم خلال الايام القليله الماضيه
عبر ميناء بورتسودان وما يقدر لاكثر من
سته الاف غادروا عبر مطار بورسودان الدولي
الى وجهات دوليه مختلفه ومع استمرار
عمليات الاجلاء الا ان مئات من الاسر
السوريه واليمنيه ما تزال حتى اليوم في
انتظار استكمال اجراءات مغادرتها للبلاد
احنا مطالبين اكثر من نوع يتم اجلانه احنا
مطالبين من اي بلد يقعدوا في الناس او
يستضيفهم شكرا احنا بس بدنا ممر امن من
هنا الى الح السوريه وشكرا البعض افضل
البقاء داخل مركز التسجيل والحصر هنا
واخرون عملت السلطات المحليه على توفير
دور مؤقته لاوائهم في ظل ظروف يحاول الجهد
الرسمي والشعبي بمدينه بورسودان تخفيف
وطاتها على العائلات والنساء والاطفال
الموجودين حاليا بشرق السودان نزار
البغداوي لقناتي العربيه والحدث مدينه
بورسودان الشرقيه السودان
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات